well the FAA has for decades been one of
the most trusted institutions in
government and for good reason
commercial air travel has been the
safest in the world in part because of
the FAS high standards but under the
obama administration that began to
change radically without anybody paying
attention the Obama administration
pressured the FAA to meet abstract
diversity goals now nobody bothered to
explain why diversity is a relevant
criterion for air traffic controllers no
one will explain it now we call the FAA
today and we got silence when we ask
that question which is the most basic
question but it didn't matter starting
in 2014 the FAA added a biographical
questionnaire to the application process
applicants with a lower aptitude in
science that preference over applicants
who scored excellent in science
applicants who'd been unemployed for the
previous three years got more points
than licensed pilots got in other words
the FAA actively searched for
unqualified air-traffic controllers that
is insane and they knew it was insane
when they did it but they did it anyway
today we obtained new information it is
an internal email written by an
executive at the firm that devised the
FAS biographical questionnaire in that
email the executive admits that the test
he devised has nothing to do with
finding the best air traffic controllers
if you want good air traffic controllers
find people with experience that was his
advice the FAA ignored this and used the
biographical screen anyway they didn't
care about finding the best air traffic
controllers compared to diversity your
safety meant nothing to them we reached
out to Greg Martin he's the FA s top
spokesman we wanted to know why the FAA
would ever use totally irrelevant
criteria such as what people look like
in order to hire for a job is vital as
air traffic control we couldn't get an
answer we also asked the Acting FAA
Administrator Daniel E well to come on
the show and explain what exactly is
going on and why he was too cowardly to
appear so was the previous administrator
Michael Huerta he's the one who
originally signed off on the policy he's
also a coward but we're gonna keep
pushing until we get an answer in the
meantime we're joined by former air
traffic controller Michael Pierce
he's also a lawyer and assuming the FAA
over all of this Michael welcome back to
the show thanks for having me on toast I
want to be certain I didn't mistake that
the biographical screen which was
devised under the Obama administration
for the reasons I just explained was
created by a company that admitted that
it was not the right way to find the
most talented air-traffic controllers
but the FAA kept it in anyway is that
correct
oh that's correct actually you didn't
missed a that you understated what
occurred to put this story in a nutshell
in 2000 late 2011 early 2012 members of
the National Black controllers
Association had a meeting with the
Rainbow PUSH coalition Jesse Jackson and
some high-level do T and F a officials
Michael Huerta was part of those
meetings by the way and right after that
meeting the FA put an immediate hold on
hiring they stopped hiring they've used
excuses like sequester but that's not
really what happened basically they shut
down the process even though the nation
needed air traffic controllers lots were
retiring the system was was needing new
trainees to go through the system
because it takes a period of time to get
through but they did that consciously
then the purge of the 2600 or more
qualified CTI students and graduate of
programs across this country including
traditionally black colleges and
disadvantaged colleges were wiped off a
list and by the way that lists the 2600
folks included a large percentage of
female and minority applicants it would
have been fantastic air traffic
controllers so these are people who'd
been who were going to school for it
basically going to school for it had
prior military experience in the area
where pilots some of these individuals
were more qualified certainly than than
I was when I started then after that
they designed a test you're speaking
about the biographical assessment
biographical questionnaire it's it's
varied in terms but this verse was
called a biographical assessment that
was made for a different purpose as you
stated it wasn't supposed to be used the
way it was and actually the creator
actually notified the FAA that they use
anyway in effect
test punished people with any aviation
knowledge any air traffic control
experience any aviation experience any
science experience and then the FAA came
out and they actually had one individual
public relations the Southwest Region
published that it was for diversity and
that was pulled back immediately and
then they state it was for the best and
brightest candidates since this is so
rotten and corrupt I don't think anybody
wants to live in a country or you can't
trust air-traffic control because
they're so dogmatically ideological that
they're intentionally seeking the worst
candidates it's insane very quickly what
about all the unions and all the pilots
groups private commercial pilots groups
what about all the people in aviation
world who knew this was going on why did
nobody say anything about it
well I think certain groups did try to
save something but quite frankly there
wasn't enough press coverage on it and
because of other political reasons it
didn't come to the forefront the bigger
question is after those students were
purged then the FAA literally knew that
there were individuals engaged in
cheating to pass the new biographical
assessment so they wiped the students
off the list they allowed a group to
then engage in intentional cheating gave
basically the subgroup the National
black coalition of federal aviation
employees the answers to that test and
that's as big of a story as anything
else what is that happened and we're
unfortunately we're out of time but this
will not be the last time we addressed
this this is a threat to the country
it's totally wrong and it can only
happen in secrecy and we plan to pierce
that so thank you Michael for all your
help with this I know we'll talk to you
again thank you it goes deep and broad
thank you very much thank you